the tents and basic dwellings at the
camp
offered no defense as multiple fires
broke out at the sprawling facility
where over twelve thousand people were
packed into a space
intended for just two thousand
by early morning officials said almost
all of the facility was destroyed
with people forced onto the roads and
fields outside
men women and children now left with no
shelter at all
it's very very very very very very
difficult basically
this also is very bad and it was a
really big fire and almost all the
camper
and we don't know where to go and all
the refugees are outside and
try to find a place to just at least
stay
the fire started around midnight at the
camp which was under lockdown after an
asylum seeker tested positive for
covid19 last week
more than 30 people were found to have
the virus this week
and a government spokesman said the
thousands who were living in moria
should not be allowed to leave the
island because of the outbreak
aid workers say police have blocked them
from getting vital supplies to the
vulnerable
it's going to be a challenge to to try
and get aid to these people and
unfortunately when you're supported by
the authorities
and by those who have on the island who
are very much
anti-refugee it's it's become really
difficult
police are investigating reports the
fires were started deliberately
the immediate challenge though is to
find shelter for thousands of people
one local mayor has said ships might
have to be used
the eu agreed to fund the transfer of
hundreds of unaccompanied children and
teenagers to the greek mainland
but there is pressure on eu nations to
do much
much more to help michelle clifford sky
news